this is one of the hardest calculus  homework questions I've seen what is the  integral of 3 sine X plus four all over  the square of 3 plus 4 sine X  to solve this problem we have to use one  weird trick divide both the numerator  and the denominator by the square of  cosine X  the numerator will simplify to be three  tangent X secant x plus four times the  square of secant x the denominator will  simplify to be the square of 3 secant x  plus four tangent X  we then substitute into the integral we  now let U be equal to 3 secant x plus  four tangent X this means d u is exactly  equal to the numerator DX so the  integral then becomes d u divided by U  squared which is equal to negative 1  over U plus C and so we get the answer  of negative 1 divided by 3 secant x plus  four tangent X plus c